okay
all right good morning everybody welcome
to transportation sorry we're a couple
of minutes late
uh before we get started if i can have
everybody rise for the pledge
thank you very much for that
uh
you do have see the list we're not
necessarily going to go in that order
and hold on one second
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 310
chair recognizes representative hill
from ocean
atl is there a second
taken by representative o'hara
did you care to speak to your motion
thank you senate bill 310 whoa
um
is uh dealing with license plate
scanners and uh
the prime sponsor came and spoke to us
primarily
as a result of
one person as far as we know although
in reading the bill it would seem that
there
must be other people that would
would also be in the same situation
but we are have
no knowledge from the bill's language
whether that is the case
the only change the bill
makes
otherwise is to
allow
a license plate reader to be installed
or mounted in a vehicle that is attended
to and operated by a law enforcement
officer
aside from that there's a new section
that
that would allow a private property
owner to
to have a license plate reader for the
sole purpose of gaining entry to
vehicles whose owners have owners have
contracted individually with the
property owner to have their license
plate scanned
i think
we are
agreed that it um
la goodlawn never comes from one
one person one industry so um for that
those reasons i think we would
prefer we itl house bill 310
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
seeing none uh last to clerk to call the
roll
uh the motion is itl on house bill 310
uh senate bill 310
vice chairman cagney
yes
representative smith yes
cleric votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative gorski yes
represent o'hara
yes
representative
udom o'brien
yes
representative clutier
representative sykes i'm sorry no
problem yes
representative fenton yeah
representative horrigan
yes representative rich
representative
yes representative fox yes
representative stevens yes and
representative ron yes and chairman
walsh
yes
one more time
eighteen to zero
okay uh our committee's recommendation
is 18-0 senate bill 310 i heard somebody
move consent
that was representative seconded without
objection consent it is
i close to the executive session on
senate bill 310 give me a minute to
reset
hmm
what'd you do
okay
i'm gonna open up the executive session
on senate bill 311.
that is the relatives who access
to driver's license information for
health care and motor vehicle related
business purposes
chair recognizes representative talersky
for a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to make a
motion of itl and senate bill 311.
thank you thank you representative ito
has been motioned uh motioned and
seconded by representative gagne would
you care to speak to your motion i will
briefly
um
we have seen
similar attempts
in the past to allow um scanning of
drivers licenses
and
retention of the information
and some of the concerns that we have
seen
is
privacy issues
issues that may conflict with our
constitution regards to the right to
privacy
um
but
in particular with this bill i believe
we discovered that the
rather broad definitions uh for who
would have access to this information
was quite concerning
quote health care business purposes
extremely broad we had testimony that it
could be a hospital a doctor's office
cvs walmart
i just have extreme
issues with the fact that that
information would be available
without any limitation on what that
actually is
we also had concerns about the fact that
um
in the section on motor vehicle business
purposes there was no consequence if the
holder of the driver's license refused
to allow scanning
i had a problem with that and i think we
also when we came right out and asked
how much
identity fraud is happening in our state
um it was
not as rampant as we would have thought
that we should
move on such an extreme change to our
current statute which protects
uh the privacy of our individuals so
for those reasons and others that i
won't go into
i support the itl
thank you very much anybody else from
the committee
seeing none i'll just mention uh thank
you for that representative i agree with
everything you said
uh i'll go one step further and a couple
of years ago our citizens
pretty much instructed us to do
everything we can to protect their
information not just pass it along to
make it convenient for others and and
through the public hearings
i did not see a demonstrated need for
this um to put that at risk so for that
i'll encourage everybody to support the
ito
uh with nobody else i'll ask the chair
to call the role the motion is i.t
support
i mean did i say
the clerk to call the rule the motion
the motion before us is
ito on senate bill 311
you mr chair
vice chairman gagan
yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
poudom o'brien yes
representative sykes
yes
representative claudia uh yes
representative fenton yes representative
horrigan yes representative rich
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative wrong yes and
chairman walsh
yes
18-0
okay
the committee's recommendation on senate
bill 311
for itl it was adopted 18-0 i heard a
motion for consent was that you
representative gagne seconded by
representative hill any objections to
consent
seeing none i'll close the executive
session on senate bill 311.
um a couple of minutes to reset we will
go to 389 next
i hope everybody's ready
okay i'm gonna open up the executive
session on senate bill 389
this is
relative to
defining mobile service garages and
relative to state vehicle inspections
the chair recognizes representative
gorsky for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion to otp senate bill 389
motions ought to pass is there a second
second
second by representative gagne would you
care to speak your motion
i do thank you mr chairman
um
listening to testimony on this
particular bill one of the things that
struck me is that you know this these
mobile garages
are to provide convenience for new
hampshire citizens
and these garages tend to be around the
large employers
since they had a one of those mobile
garages here i happen to go down and you
know kind of look in and i actually
walked in them
and it looked you know fairly
uh stable it seemed
very worthy in terms of the repairs that
they do
and to add state vehicle inspections i
thought i think is
um worthy for new hampshire citizens to
allow for the convenience and based on
all that
i think uh you know otpness and allowing
this for the convenience of the citizens
of new hampshire is a good thing
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative sykes
thank you mr chairman
um as a co-sponsor of this bill i'm
obviously in support of it i have been
in support of the concept for
more than one session we looks like i
hope that we are finally going to get
this
done for the people for the citizens of
new hampshire so that they have
a way to
get their cars inspected with less
impact than having to take a day out of
work for instance
and so accordingly i urge
the committee to vote in favor of the
ought to pass motion
thank you anybody else
seeing them i'll ask the clerk to call
the role the motion before us is ought
to pass on senate bill 389.
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith
yes
clerk of ots representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
donald o'brien
yes representative sykes
yes representative clutier yes
representative fenton yeah
representative horrigan yes
representative rich
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative wrong yes and
chairman walsh
yes
18 to
that will move consent okay
and where am i here
our committee recommendation of ought to
pass on senate bill 389 uh as adopted i
have a motion for consent by
representative gagne was that seconded
second by representative travis any
objections for consent
cnn i'll close
the
executive session on senate bill 389.
we'll go into
senate bill 406 next
one
he hasn't acknowledged
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 406 relative to
driver's license reciprocity chair
recognizes representative sikes for
emotion
thank you mr chairman i move ought to
pass
thank you sir is there a second
oop seconded by representative o'hara
would you care to speak your motion
yes thank you mr chairman so this bill
is um was originally introduced at the
request of the department of safety
and
also
they did testify in favor of the bill
lieutenant leary from
the new hampshire state police who
oversees the driver's ed program and
other
staff members and it is a
bipartisan effort on
those from the other side of the wall as
we often say
and accordingly i would think that this
is a good thing for us to do for
making it a little easier for people who
take their drivers at elsewhere and
give the
dmv the authority to
establish those standards
for drivers at
thank you sir everybody anybody else
from the committee
seeing none the only thing i'll add is
uh roman two of part two of the bill
actually is a service to our citizens uh
we learned in public hearing that
actually the definitions of a lot of the
violations in other states are more
severe than ours and so this will allow
the the commissioner to interpret
and compare what those uh violations are
in other states and apply them to what
is codified in new hampshire law so this
is a good thing and a good good clear
for clarifier
um nobody else from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the rule the motion is
uh to pass on senate bill 406
vice chairman gagney yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hara yes representative
dom o'brien yes representative sykes yes
representative clutier yes
representative fenton yeah
representative oregon yes representative
richard representative rich
so yes
representative
yes representative fox
yes representative stevens yes
representative wrong yes chairman walsh
yes
18-0
okay
um
our committee recommendation of ought to
pass on 406 is adopted representative
gagne moves consent is there second
seconded by representative thompson any
objection
seeing none consent that is i'll close
the executive session on senate bill 406
and we will do four four nine next four
seven nine nine okay
okay i'm gonna open up the
executive session on senate bill 449
relative to the retention of social
security numbers by the division of
motor vehicles
chair recognizes representative thompson
for a motion
uh mr chairman i'd like to move itl on
senate bill 449. motion is itl is there
a second
represented by
uh seconded by representative gagne
would you care to speak to your motion
i'm offset
yeah thank you
anybody from the committee
representative sykes
yeah so this
um part of my concern about this bill
was that first off the secretary of
state's office did not offer any
testimony on the day of the bill and
that is always concerning to me when a
big part of the questions raised by this
bill concerns that department
so i it's i think it's incumbent upon us
to recognize that um i'm also concerned
that it might in fact violate the new
the new part of our state constitution
looking for protections of privacy which
have long been
one of the
i don't want to call it the prime
directive of this committee but this
committee has always been in support of
protecting persons privacy and
accordingly
i would urge members of the committee to
vote
uh itl
anybody else from the committee
well
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready
motion is ito on senate bill 449.
uh vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill
yes representative thompson yes
representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
for donald o'brien yes representative
sykes
yes representative clutier yes
representative fenton yes representative
horrigan yes representative rich
representative trulersky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative wrong yes
represent chairman walsh
yes
okay our committee
recommendation of
itl on senate bill 449 that's adopted
uh 18-0 uh motion for consent
representative gagne is our second
second by representative gorski and the
objections to consent singing none i'll
close the executive session on senate
bill 449.
okay that was the easy part
yeah
um hold on one moment
okay i'm going to uh
in light of some new information and
talking points i'm going to recess our
meeting until
11 15.
see you then
democrats are going to move to the
office
all right welcome back
to transportation
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 308 relative to
driver's licenses for certain visa
holders chair recognizes representative
gagne for a motion
thank you mr chairman i make a motion
for interim study
on sb 308 interim study has been moved
is there a second second second by
representative is that thompson thompson
i care to speak to your motion briefly
briefly it is mr chairman because there
are so many
questions about this bill
that the only way that we could get done
to the bottom of making this
viable would be to go interim study and
really do a good interim study and get
to a proper solution
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative sykes
so
um because i have great respect for the
chair and his vice chair and take it
there take their word that this will be
a legitimate interim study
um even though i've been a uh
co-sponsor of this bill i will i would
urge my colleagues to support the
interim study motion
thank you for that anybody else from the
committee
seeing none i i will echo that um of all
the bills we had here i have to be
honest this is the one we worked on the
hardest we had meetings with the
department of motor vehicles
uh with the senator with the farm bureau
and i think there is something we can
get to that does give some relief to
them but it seems every time we get an
answer on one issue we came up with a
question on another um and just looking
at the deadlines
uh i'm grateful we could agree
and this will not be a death with
dignity this will be a legitimate
interim study and i i believe it's the
right way to go forward with this and i
ask everybody on the committee
uh to
to approve the interim study
anybody else
being on the motion is interim study
on senate bill 308 i'll ask the clerk to
call the rope
vice chairman gaggy yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative gorski yes
represent o'hare yes representative
prudhomme o'brien yes representative
sykes
yes
representative clutier uh yes
representative fenton yes representative
horrigan yes representative rich
representative tulerski yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative wrong yes
chairman walsh
yes
uh our committee recommendation of
interim studies approved adopted 18-0
consent's been moved by representative
gagner second seconded by representative
o'hara
uh that closed at the executive session
on senate bill 308
we'll go on to senate bill 309 next
i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 309
authorizing certain organizations to
issue decal plates chair recognizes
representative gagne for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move ought to
pass on
uh senate bill 309
uh motions ought to pass is there a
second
seconded by representative hill
the motion's ought to pass but this is
open for further amendment chair
recognizes representative talersky for a
motion
thank you i'd like to move uh amendment
number 2022-17108
seconded by representative o'hara would
you care to speak to motion i would
thank you
um
the amendment is very simple
it just strikes line four of the
original bill and i'd like to just uh
give you some of the reasons why i
decided to draft the amendment
the organization that's listed didn't
show up to our hearing
and upon looking at the senate hearing
notes they didn't show up to the senate
hearing either
as we know and we learned a few weeks
ago we have received feedback from an
organization that is part of the decal
program has been in the program for a
little over three years now
and there are relatively small
organization but they said it was the
biggest mistake they've ever made as a
nonprofit
they did not fully understand the
financial um implication of what they
had to put into the program
and in the end um they discovered that
it has now cost them 1200
they're in the whole 1200 and they've
sold only 12 decals
um
and they wish they had never done it
they didn't fully understand it
i brought this forward to the committee
a couple months ago and i
said i think it's our place to make sure
that these organizations fully
understand the program what they're
getting into and have them
agree that they know what they're
getting into we know that the program
works for certain organizations
some of the larger ones it's great i
think that the
girl scouts of the white mountains that
we passed earlier i think that they will
really
excel with the program and i'm happy
that that one's gone through
we've seen the university system has
also flourished with the program it
works for large organizations
i think it would be unfair for us to
just push
one through without
being assured that they understand what
they're getting into
they can always come back in the future
but i
would like to think that we're doing
a good thing by giving them a chance to
understand what they're getting into
before sinking uh
you know much needed money that they use
into a program like this
so anyway i do wanted to
allow i did want to allow the new
hampshire towing association to move
through i did speak with that
organization after the hearing um
they were a little surprised that they
got
grouped in with another group and they
just they were
um fine with having this amendment
drafted so i would support my colleagues
to
vote for this amendment thank you
thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative hill
i concur with everything that
representative talersky just said
thank you is there anybody else from the
committee
seeing none um
the the motion before us is the adoption
of amendment
2022-101710h
[Music]
with no further discussion all those in
favor of adopting the amendment say aye
aye opposed nay
that is unanimous the amendment is
adopted
so now we are too hot to pass as amended
um
that was representative
gagne would you care to speak to the
motion
uh thank you mr chairman um
representative talarsky pretty much
summarized it all in regards to
a certain organization not showing up
and really not knowing what's going on
what what the cost would be for all this
therefore the uh
the ought to pass as amended would be
the better way to go which authorizes
the new hampshire towing association
for the cows
thank you sir anybody else
being none and let's look at the
original bill after the amendment uh
this also
allows the towing association to
issue decals that will give some
recognition to our move over law so that
is a good thing
with no other discussion the motion is
ought to pass as amended on senate bill
309 i'll ask the clerk to call the roll
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes clerk ots
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
dome o'brien yes representative sykes
yes representative claudia yes
representative fenton yes representative
horrigan
yes representative rich
representative
yes representative fox yes
representative stevens yes
representative wrong yes chairman walsh
yes
18 to 0.
all right our committee recommendation
about to pass as amendment is adopted
18-0 i heard representative
o'hara move consent is there a second
second by representative gagne any
objection to consent singing then i'll
close the executive session on house
bill 309
and we have one left
we'll move into 447 in a moment
i'll open up the executive session on
senate bill 447
establishing the electric vehicle and
infrastructure fund
the chair recognizes representative
smith for a motion
thank you mr chair i move icl on senate
bill 447.
motions itl is there a second
by representative o'hara care to speak
to your motion
uh sure uh i served on the
electric charging vehicle infrastructure
commission for a few years
um that was an outcrop of
one of the things that we could spend
the volkswagen trust fund settlement
money on
a lot of progress was made
corridors were established but this is a
program that's in its infancy
until we see how some of that works out
and we start getting data back on the
cost benefit the impact on electric
rates it doesn't make sense to me to do
this sort of
massive expansion of a program that
hasn't been proven yet
so not against the concept and this is a
bill i might vote for in five years but
not today
thank you sir anybody from the committee
representative sykes
so
um
this is a concept whose time has come
in fact
if you imagine such an american icon
vehicle as the corvette will be
fully electric shortly
that cummins diesel is changing all of
their truck their engines to
electric
and we
i have spoken again and again and again
about how
we as a state need to be prepared for
things as they are
when they arrived not oh they're here
now what are we going to do about it it
should be
we're prepared for the arrival of the of
this
new industry with jobs
changing the way we do things i
characterize it as being
sort of like back in the days when
uh the
decisions were being made about where to
put the new interstate
system
and there were winners and losers in
that interstate system
program and i will speak to my area of
the state particularly
um the interstate went through lebanon
and it didn't go through claremont even
though claremont was a larger city at
that time
subsequent to that city of claremont has
gone through some exceptionally
difficult times and their population
continues to go down
at least until very recently whereas
lebanon's continues to go up
with with a really low unemployment rate
etc
we should be preparing to make sure that
our state is one of the winners in this
and it is time for us to have a
mechanism to
deal with the very different numbers of
funding sources that already exist
federal money
vw money there's a whole bunch of them
um i would urge the committee the
members of the committee to vote against
the
itl because there is a amendment that
would improve the bill
that we would be prepared to offer um
if we get it not to pass
so again
it's time to
wake up and smell the coffee let's just
say this these electric vehicles are
coming
and we need to be set up as a state in
order to
uh best do what the
what we are here to try and accomplish
anybody else from the committee
representative horrigan um i agree
well first of all if this truly is
premature
there's not much harm in passing it
because there won't be any
funds to put in the uh either give
directly to drt or put in this fund
depending what form the bill passes in
so there's no harm into it but there is
in fact a lot of interest a lot of money
this is the wave of the future of
normally the corvette is going electric
even the ford f-150 is going electric um
that most traditionally fuel guzzling of
all vehicles so this is uh
and uh especially
um
those other states with higher taxes
where our tourists come from they're
investing heavily in
electric charging vehicles for their
tourist traffic i noticed for example
last summer i was down in
lee massachusetts which is right near
the new york massachusetts state line
and they've
set up about
20 electric charging stations at the
right off the first exit off of the
massachusetts turnpike and so those
those people can charge up and almost
make it to new hampshire but they may be
worried about how much farther they can
go in new hampshire and actually
ironically
this makes especially a big difference
in the north country because
electric vehicle chargers are
vehicle owners are not quite sure if
there'll be any place for them to charge
it if they get up to you know sugar hill
or berlin or any of the other
communities in northern new hampshire
have a lot to offer so i think this is
something that is very much very much
needed um there's
a burgeoning demand for it i um
i was we had an electric vehicle uh
showcase in new hampshire and i'm i mean
i personally still drive a volvo what
they call an ice engine internal
combustion so i'm driving a gas guzzler
but there's um
a wide variety of people who are very
enthusiastic about their uh
about their electric vehicles not just
the hybrids but also the all-electric
vehicles and so i think
i think we need to pass this bill
immediately so dot and the other
agencies can get to work in this right
away rather than waiting five years or
even waiting until
uh the end of the 2023 budget cycle so i
would certainly urge us to
get on the stick and pass
either
preferably the amended bill or failing
that the original bill so i would say
i say this is not premature this is
actually overdue and um so we
you know we need we need to get started
uh before the leaf peeping season two we
want to make sure those leaf peepers
from massachusetts new york can get
all the way up to the north country and
back without uh
without running out of electricity so
i i say past this thanks
anybody else from the committee
representative i'll be very brief i just
want to um
emphasize that
not having this program
in place to manage these monies we heard
in testimony that
having this bill in place will help us
when we apply for grants and different
funds
we've already heard with the previous
bill that new hampshire's
behind the times behind the eight ball
we can't even get electric vehicles into
the state to sell
this is just gonna put us one step more
than one step behind
all of the other states that are going
to be advancing this technology it makes
us look like we're living in the dark
age and i would encourage
my colleagues to vote against the itl
anybody else from the committee
we'll leave it there we could go on for
hours on this debate
the uh
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll the
motion is itl on
senate bill 447 fn
vice chairman cagney
yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
o'brien yes representative sykes
no representative claudia no
representative fenton no representative
again no representative rich
talersky no representative fox
no representative stevens no
representative wrong no and chairman
walsh yes
nine to
nine right the recommendation of itl
um
nine nine fails
i'll entertain another motion
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman i move um
otp
motion is ought to pass on
senate bill four four seven fn is there
a second
and uh represented uh seconded by
representative fenton
now we actually have an amendment to
introduce as well
another one besides my mind no that
that's the one i've decided i'm not
gonna enter my my
amendment
okay
then i don't i guess i don't have one
after all
um anyways i'll speak to my motion when
it's time
a point of order mr chair where is that
coming from
representative wrong um
it's my understanding that amendment can
be introduced from anyone it doesn't
have to be from the person that
sponsored the amendment
is that that is that not the case in
this committee that is true
okay
so can represent so my understanding is
that even though representative sykes
didn't sponsor the amendment that he
could still move it to the committee
let me hold on one second for some
clarification
why not get foreign right that's where
that's the direction we're gonna go um
just for clarification uh after
consulting a few uh i did get the
amendment drafted i do not want to see
the amendment going to go forward with
my name on it uh so therefore i'm not
gonna entertain it being introduced in
terms of the language being used which
is fine for somebody else to introduce
we just don't have time today so the
best option would be uh we'll go through
the vote on the ought to pass and if
it's successful or whatever the outcome
this could be introduced as a floor
amendment
the the the change is basically in the
first section and believe it or not the
uh department of transportation didn't
even recognize this until the 11th hour
either
they were fine with it because the
fiscal note was uh indeterminal
indeterminable um
so the amendment
uh i i will no longer support moving
this forward with my name on it so
that's where we're at so we're not going
to be taking up this amendment the
motion on the floor is ought to pass any
more on the ought to pass motion
well i just i will say mr chairman that
i disagree with the
tactics that are taking place here i
think that
we have an obligation to do when we get
informate further information as uh
things come across that would improve a
bill that we're trying to vote on that
we should take steps
in a cleaner process here now today
i understand though that you are chair
and there we are yep and time is time
that is the major reason for my decision
uh anything else on the out to pass
i'll just reiterate again this is a very
um
this can't be
this is an issue that dot will have to
deal with anyway in this either version
build and make it give them a lot more
flexibility this isn't something we want
to put out for five years it isn't
really even something we want to put off
until uh you know
the spring of 2023 whenever the next
legislature passes this new budget and
goes through all that rigmarole so i
think this um
enables them to get to work now and
certainly um
those other states we like to make fun
of with their high taxes liberal
policies their uh drivers are
are by switching to electric vehicles in
large number and they expect our state
like other states to have a adequate
infrastructure in place to support them
so i would
so just so just urge committee to pass
you know at least the original bill
thanks thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative yes thank you mr chairman
um i support the otp i'm amazed that
people think this is uh not ready for
prime time because
electric vehicles are all over the place
i mean if you go down starting in
virginia and work your way north they're
growing and growing we are not prepared
i look at the traffic in the lakes
region in the summer and it's going to
really hurt us with tourism if we don't
have the infrastructure to allow people
with electric vehicles to be able to
recharge
i echo my colleague from durham's
remarks about
that our tourism industry is going to
rely on this infrastructure to be in
place and we cannot wait anymore the
time is now thank you
anybody else
representative sykes i'll give you one
more thank you sir um
just as another
point being illustrative that this is
not too early
the upper valley
will have electric buses
in operation before the end of
next year they're already purchased and
they're gonna
this is coming folks
this is coming that's all i can tell you
anybody else
representative smith
thank you mr chair all that aside i mean
we're talking about spending state money
and government money on doing this and i
think the issue of the approach is
probably what we disagree with more
we you put in a tourist attraction
you also put in bathrooms because people
are not likely to go spend the day
someplace that does not have a bathroom
you may have a concession stand because
if you want them to stay there for six
hours they'll get hungry if they're
driving an electric car i would imagine
that these places would then put in
charges if they want to attract that and
then use it as a marketing device and
i'm going to go back to the point where
i think it's early to begin subsidizing
this i prefer to see how the industry
develops it all by itself
amen
anybody else from the committee
he just defused me which is probably a
good thing
representative pilerski i am going to be
so very quick
i simply want to react to what was just
stated
and
while i don't
the first statement made on this is
having state funds
spent i was frantically looking through
my bill here to see where that actually
states that i believe i understood
my colleague was then saying that we
would have to build bathrooms and
concession stands
i guess i will then just take the very
quick leap
because he's talking about attracting
more people up here
if i misunderstood i apologize
to me that sounded like
growing business
growing dollars
people spending money
which is i thought what we were trying
to encourage here
and that's what i believe
this bill
does by drawing people in so that they
can come and spend money and i apologize
if i totally misunderstood what was just
said
thank you
anybody else from the community
representative smith thank you yeah yeah
you did
the point was
that the state or the federal government
didn't pay for the bathrooms they didn't
pay for the concessions concession
stands and at this point i don't know if
we need to pay for the electric charges
or create this sort of
infrastructure and i don't know
potential bureaucracy because the
businesses might do it all by themselves
if they think it's a good draw
that was the only point
and i do agree with that
in premise first of all i don't know if
if the manufacturers are moving towards
electric vehicles because everybody
wants them i don't believe that to be
true i believe they're moving towards
electric vehicles because they're being
compelled to
uh when we get to the infrastructure of
it i was all fine with taking the
volkswagen trust fund money and using
that towards creating the corridors
um but when you get to us or even the
federal money with its taxpayer money
also actually spending the money on the
infrastructure to recharge personals
individual vehicles doesn't make any
sense to me you see tesla chargers all
over the planet so why don't we see ford
and gm and all these other ones
why aren't they bringing the money into
the situation why is it the taxpayers
that have to build the infrastructure
another possibility that happens is we
spend all this money all these millions
of dollars in in five years and the
batteries improve so much that half the
infrastructure we put in is no longer
necessary these are all the things that
do
legitimize the statement that we're not
ready for this yet um so i please
encourage everybody to vote against the
ought to pass
anybody else from the committee
representative
i'll just be quick um when we just had a
clarification from the representative
from the department of transportation
that this bill as amended would allow
the state would allow the dot to
contract with private
entities to come in and build this
infrastructure this is not the state
doing it themselves and it is my
understanding that would also be
allowing
paid charges i mean this isn't all just
for us putting up chargers with free
electricity going to vehicles um so i
guess we will probably continue to agree
mr chairman and i appreciate you giving
me more than enough opportunities to
speak thank you
i would stop i would not stop being fair
on our last day here so
um and again it's not about
nobody disagrees that ultimately people
are going to have to pay for the
electricity that comes out of these
charging systems but there's we're still
being looked at as being spending
taxpayer money on the infrastructure
itself now if every charge
had a surcharge that went towards paying
for the infrastructure and made it
almost like a bond i'd look at this a
whole lot differently but that's not
what it does uh so you're right i think
we're probably going to disagree i
i'll leave it at that
anybody else from the committee
cnn i'll ask the clerk to call the rule
on
ought to pass on senate bill 447 fn
is chairman cagney no
representative smith no
workboats no representative hill no
representative thompson no
representative no
representative o'hare no representative
o'brien no
representative sykes
yes representative clutier yes
representative fenton yeah
representative horrigan yes
representative rich
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative wrong yes
chairman walsh
no
nine to nine
okay nine to nine on the out to pass
that follows the nine to nine on the itl
so i recognize the impasse we're at uh
again uh some may think it's unfair we
just do not have the time to entertain
any amendments
uh they can be done on the floor uh i am
going to close the executive session on
this this will go to the calendar
without recommendation the motion on the
floor when we get there will be out to
pass and we can have this discussion all
over again
so before we all leave
uh well you got a hearing
okay
before we do leave um
i
the deadline is the 28th if you've got
reports uh please get them to me today
it is really enough i've got a couple of
do myself um but before we do go i want
to thank everybody i can't believe
even though we had to end on this note
um
that this is the last day of our
committee work for this term i think you
can all agree it's been a very
interesting one
and i
can't believe that it was almost a year
and a half ago when i walked in this
room with my brand new laptop saying
what the heck is zoom
so
it's been quite a haul
um again i want to thank everybody i
want to thank representative o'hara for
being my my aide during the initial zoom
days because i had no idea what i was
doing
um but i
again too just want to express that i
hope
uh and i did do my best to hold up the
traditions of the transportation
committee through this whole process
we still had some fun we had some laughs
we got our work done
and even though we don't agree on
everything it's
it's how you disagree that makes the
difference and i think we were able to
get through our work disagree
forget it shrug it off with no grudges
take on the next one and again i want to
thank you for well thank you all of that
here
do we have any senate messages yet do
you know
thank you for reminding me i have not
got the official senate message but the
only amended bill we have
uh and i'll get the message and and
respond to it was the
railroad bill uh representative
o'brien's all they did was change some
pronouns they didn't change anything in
the bill so
uh being relieved that the pronouns are
now correct i would imagine we'll concur
with the changes
so
uh but when i do see um i did get a side
by side you know brad if you could email
everybody on the committee the side by
side on that uh that way i can just get
a yes or no when they do actually see it
uh that's the only one i've gotten so
far i have been paying attention to the
senate
it's the only one i know so far that
they've actually amended
so they've either been passing or
killing
that's how it goes
so
with that if nobody else has anything
yeah okay representative sykes so i
would like to echo the chairman's words
this committee
has a history of working together to try
and come up with the best solutions
we almost always find our way there once
in a while we don't
but it's
it's been my experience that we've
we have been able to disagree and not be
disagreeable and i think that's
really important and i look forward to
further work with members of this
committee
in the next session
thank you for that anybody else
being done we'll see you next session
thanks again
you